good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy tuesday that has
huge monday energy like hme such a
monday vibe
such a beautiful thing to behold you
wake up you think it's monday
nope it's tuesday i hope everyone
enjoyed their
three or four days off of alarm free
living i know i did
i feel like everyone okay so many things
that i we need to recap this weekend but
i feel like everyone had like a really
great weekend didn't you get that vibe
i mean the peeps were out in the masses
right even though like the weather was
trash pretty much like
everywhere on the water seaboard
or borg i think i'm gonna say sea board
because i have no idea what a borg is
yeah i'm thinking like a smorgasbord
yeah yeah no it's
definitely bored it's definitely boring
yes sea board
on the eastern seaboard the weather was
on the right but it felt like everybody
was having a really good time i know
that we had a really good time
even with the inclement weather so i'm
just really happy for all of us that
like we had that time i mean
i've said it once i'll say it again
we're living in a post-pandemic world
and people don't want to be found that's
what i'm gathering and it's actually
something i'm really struggling with
because i know it's kind of crazy i've
been spoken about it like
my birthday's on saturday and i'm just
glad you're gonna say that the paparazzi
right
shut up stop no my birthday's on
saturday and like
honestly i'm just feeling like i don't
really want to celebrate the fact that
i'm actually becoming a grandma
but then it's like we're living in a
post-pandemic world i'm really not going
to throw myself a birthday party i feel
like this is something maybe a lot of us
summer birthday people are struggling
with
um it's tough i think it's what
everybody struggles with over the age of
i want to say 25 because like
from like 18 to 25 you can get away with
just like a pregame for your birthday
but like now nobody wants to do that you
can get away with like a table at a club
nobody wants to know we're so old now
like it has to be more civilized
yeah and like those things take time as
money
hard to plan where do you get a private
venue like it's just so hard
no and then it's like having a summer
birthday and living in the city it's
like people are all over for this
for the for the summer like some people
are in the hampton some people are away
so
i know these aren't like real problems
but that's kind of what i'm currently
dealing with okay and what i'm dealing
with are the face times which i do for
my birthday
don't be rude i'm trying to make you
comfortable because i know you're very
specific wow
honestly you're at the fort like the
forefront of my planning because like
you hate everything
and i want you to like leave early you
know wow i that's like
thank you for your consideration but i
just want to say that i would say the
exact same thing about you
i don't think that's true i think you
would just do whatever you wanted like
for your birthday no
like you would leave early if you didn't
like what was happening
no by the way have you met me i'm
literally always the last person at a
party like i would never leave a party
early especially if it was yours
okay you're like the queen of like irish
exiting
that's you what no it's not
i'm always the last one at a party no no
it's actually a problem of mine i'm
working inside that
you are done yeah you are gone oh yeah
and that could happen at any point in
the night
what are you talking about like have you
ever been to a party with me
what are you talking about like i just
know when if it's not your vibe like
luckily a lot of things are fine but if
it's not your vibe like goodbye
but like if it was your birthday i would
never leave
early i don't leave early and i would
also never leave your birthday i don't
know why we're fighting about this we're
like it's been
very it's been very like harmonious yeah
we're just looking out for each other
but we also we also don't know each
other
like defensive about who's looking out
for who more no i'm really i just
like i wasn't like trying to compete
with you i was just saving facts like i
really i'm like thinking about you in my
planning like that's it that's so sweet
thank you that's so sweet and you know
what no matter what you do it's going to
be amazing because any opportunity to
celebrate you is just
always full of love and then don't you
just feel like so stupid like
like planning a birthday party like i'm
a 27 year old dope who's making like
everyone leave their houses like to come
celebrate and like sing to me it just
feels very stupid
but they would be singing when it should
be used
at some point like birthdays just stop
feeling fun and they start like you're
very self-aware
of like how dumb you are does that make
sense no i agree and so
i don't know what the right balance is
and i think it's like
obviously you need to celebrate your
birthday like another year trip around
the sun
post pandemic who am i not to throw a
birthday party that's what i'm really
struggling but maybe it's like this
expectation of not every year like needs
to be
like the biggest baddest thing just what
do you enjoy most doing what do you
enjoy doing the most
like sitting in my bed have a house
party
we'll have a house party we don't need
nobody turn your tv
off break that boom box out no for real
like what do you enjoy doing the most
like drinking with my friends and like
dancing and in what sort of environment
indoors outdoors day time night time
night time indoors yeah
sorry that's where we differ it's okay
but anyways just do a little bit of that
then
i'm just gonna figure it out it's just
something i'm currently like digesting
and this is what we do here we share
what's going on in our world we're
processing our emotions
that's what i'm processing especially
coming off such a fabulous weekend it
must be
i feel for you because you're already
thinking about the next one as you must
because you have this birthday
duty it's a big duty it's a big big
birthday it's runny
it's a big dump like it's something i'm
like i said currently processing
it's already when we just came off of
such a great weekend that it feels like
we can't even celebrate because it's on
to the next
everyone's tired i feel like everyone's
taking this weekend off because like at
least for us
i saw people out in spades in the
hamptons everyone was like turning up
doing
the most and i just don't know if people
are ready to do that again i really
don't
yeah but we did have such a great
weekend it was rainy and then sunny
luckily we got a day of sun
bruno and theo had the best day of their
lives it was such a
joy to watch them bruno was just running
around the yard like in circles
laps just because he couldn't believe he
had so much space to run then he fell in
the pool which was
so funny and so cute but he had i think
he was like so glad that he got to swim
i don't think he would have been brave
enough to jump in otherwise so i think
he enjoyed the experience
yeah and claudia is there another part
of that story
because he was obviously doggy paddling
and we saw him try to get up to the
ledge but he couldn't pull himself up so
claudia
jumped in to the cold pool and freezes
him up
to the ledge rescued bruno but everyone
keeps talking about this story and like
leaving out the part where i was the
hero like
was it not heroic because i wouldn't
have [ __ ] done it if i wasn't gonna
get attention
has been talking about it he was like
wow i didn't even know she liked me
it was [ __ ] traumatizing like seeing
him and everyone was like frozen like
and then you were like claudia go you
were the closest it was just
traumatizing but yes
amongst many things i did this weekend i
did save bruno and i am a local hero
yes and bruno was so grateful for every
every experience he had this weekend it
was really like the best
of his life and we got to spend like so
much qt with mckayla
it was really just a well-rounded
weekend like we sat we drank we ate
we did all the things like boy did we
and the weather
i have to say like a lot of people were
complaining the eastern seaboard
was very rainy but like i'm not gonna
lie on saturday
i think that if it hadn't rained my life
would be completely different
how so because on saturday we spent the
whole day inside watching
are you the one yes because we were
looking for something like neutral to
watch with the whole group
and like something's not that serious
and jackie was just like what about are
you the one
and i'd actually never seen it and we
put on a random season and like i'm
telling you the whole house was invested
it is such a good show i've been trying
to tell you we watched season two if any
one of you
already the one stands are out there
it's the season with the 11th girl
which really complicated everything so
unnecessarily because then by the end of
the season they realized that they just
left her out the whole time like the
show would be
unaffected right but it was so good i've
watched every season except for the most
recent one because
i lost mtv for a while there when like
directv dropped mtv
i love when the networks go on strike
and like we get effective no
literally so i never saw the most recent
season i actually thought there were
more seasons that i missed but
apparently it was just one
there's only two on netflix there's only
two on netflix like bring back the other
seasons to netflix it's such a good show
i'm so glad that you saw it for what it
is like it's
genuinely an interesting premise yes
and the people the people nothing to
lose
they really find like the biggest freaks
from all across our great nation and
it's wonderful to see like this
just like gathering of weirdos it's so
good the premise of the show is great
the casting is great
and honestly like it was i was so
involved i don't know when this season
aired like five years ago but i was so
involved like as if it was today
it aired in like 2015 i think okay so
like six years ago
what did i say five sorry that's just
like it feel like when you watch it it
feels like it aired ten years ago like
based on the clothes
the clothes and like the camera quality
and just like the whole editing was very
like
real world and literally i felt like if
you had told me the show was filmed in
2005 i would have believed you yeah
especially after and we'll recap it
later coming up i had just watched too
hot to handle so watching that
one on like just i'll give a compliment
to how to handle like stunning visually
colors everything the brightness like
the camera work and then to go to
something that was filmed six years ago
you actually do see a difference
um so that's a plus and two out to
handles um column but then
watching are you the one right after two
out to handle just
underscores how horrible of a show too
hot to handle is and i
stand by my statement and i've actually
converted some people claude
tell them i'm such a [ __ ] hater we're
gonna do a whole tv recap segment but i
don't even know if it's because like we
fell in love with are you the one and
then we started watching too about
handle
it those last like four episodes are a
crime against humanity they were
dreadful like i was full of dread it was
so [ __ ] horrible so boring
stretching like trying so hard to make
another episode it was so
[ __ ] bad i want to get into it
because there's a lot of offline
no no online drama like the cast and
crew oh you gotta share
yeah i know anything so we're gonna do a
whole tv recap segment on there um
because we don't watch the bachelor last
night but if you're looking for a
bachelor recap this snatcher episode
is out soon so maybe by the time this
episode just keep checking it's there
yeah snatcher oh i need to catch up with
her um so i'm going to be listening to
snatchers just to find out what's going
on in snatchers universe yeah that's
what we have to do just to keep up with
our sister
so sad miss you snatcher i love you if
you're listening i actually made her
listen to an episode of the toast
because they uh her nicole were driving
and they were bored and i was like why
don't you listen to a podcast
why don't you listen to the
[ __ ] toast so true and they did
they listened to
almost a whole episode and almost yeah
then i think they switched to joe rogan
for
i would do no but like come on snapchat
it's great stuff here
learn your lesson it's good stuff like
this is a hilarious show
we are so premium so hilarious actually
been so many toasters in the wild
um when i was out in montauk on sunday
they were all asking for you i forgot to
tell you this but i said
it's i said it's nine o'clock grandma's
asleep like wow and you literally were
wow okay i went to sleep like 11 o'clock
because i heard i heard you guys went up
at 10.
but i was up late reading oh so
technical oh the grandma stayed up late
to read
look at her so you set me up for that
joke no it's fine no it's fine
it's fine is it i know in my soul that
i'll say something today and then in
four days you're like
saying the same thing 100 like all it
takes is four days
just four days just like chase chase
let's save them for the tv okay let's
see who's because every funny story
everything i just want to say is about
too hot to handle whereas claudia came
around
four days later yeah and it's like
killing me i'm like it's oozing out of
me the hatred so we will get there but
we have a designated hatred segment
it's too hate to handle
too hate to handle i'm so excited for
that so i think without further ado
where are you right here sleeping
because he's dreaming about the most
amazing weekend that he had
it is time for the past five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode of the morning toast
is brought to you by pros
most of you guys have probably heard us
singing the praises of prose the most
the world's most personalized hair care
and for those who haven't we want to
tell you about the incredible
incredible results we are seeing since
using customized prose products
so i've definitely seen an improvement
in my hair texture so it's i
like to pride myself on having like
shiny and smooth hair and sometimes
um if i don't really take care of my
hair it can get kind of dull and that's
how i know it's like time for a refresh
and with pros i'm noticing like a bounce
back in my hair it's bouncier it's more
shiny it's more smooth and everyone's
like compliments me like your hair's so
shiny i'm like girl it's pros
pros knows that there's more to you than
just your hair type they have given over
a million consultations with their
in-depth quiz which is how we got
started too
super easy to take the quiz um they ask
questions that like
you might not even think of when it
comes to hair so it's like a really full
well-rounded
quiz they analyze over 85 factors they
determine a unique blend of ingredients
to treat your exact concerns
they also have a review and refined
feature which lets you tweak your
formulas
based on any changes of address hair
color or your diet
so if you want to get healthy hair
process healthy hair regimen with your
name all over it
literally take your free in-depth hair
consultation and get 15
off your first order today when you go
to pros.com toast
that's p-r-o-s-e-com slash toast
for your free in-depth hair consultation
if you're not 100 positive pros is the
best hair care you've had they'll take
the products back
no questions asked thank you for that
claudia now i feel ready to get into our
first story of the day which is some
happy couple news actually
three out of five today are happy couple
news so i'm happy for them the couples
are really happy
the couples are quaking first up gwen
stefani and blake shelton are married it
was a picture-perfect day for gwen
stefani and blake shelton
the superstar couple said their eye dues
on saturday in an intimate at-home
wedding at shelton's ranch
in tisha mingo oklahoma and on monday
gwen posted a series of romantic photos
from their nuptials to instagram writing
dreams do come true he wore jeans and
sky-high cowboy boots i saw it was
really cute like
obviously everyone's you know wedding
taste is unique to them and i felt like
you could have showed me this wedding
with no people in it and i would have
known exactly whose it was like it was
very true to them
i really think they're a wonderful
couple i'm so glad that like they've
both found
each other they feel like a couple that
has been together for 50 years like
they're so otp
this wedding they always do everything
like very true to them themselves and i
really like a ship hardcore
i totally agree i love that they have
their own style and they've also really
blended their two styles
which are not very similar rock glam and
country right
and they've made this rock clam country
vibe for themselves and i think that
they are very
happy well-suited couple and i'm happy
for them
also i feel like they have been together
for a really long time because they have
been
i feel like they were engaged for a
while also yes and i feel like in the
beginning of their relationship they
moved really quickly
and then they were like engaged for a
long time i just interesting nothing
like
no commentary about that yeah just an
interesting timeline timeline
um but i'm happy to see that they're
officially married now
and i wish them all the love in the
world i just can't believe this is a
relationship that makes me like each one
of them more because i was never
a blake shelton stan nor gwen stefani
but i do ship the two of them together
you know the fact that they both fell in
love with each other when they really
come from different worlds
makes me just like i don't know like die
for them in a way like
i think it's so sweet not to be true not
to be dramatic but like i would
literally take a bullet ship in front of
a bus for that
no for real like and also the thing that
i find so interesting is of course
whenever i think about blake shelton and
his like dating
drama like i always think about miranda
lambert who's like my new queen i know i
used to like talk the most [ __ ] on her
but
as we've learned sometimes all it takes
is four days um for me to change my mind
so i obviously am now thinking like
what's going through miranda's mind
because they were like the queen
and king of country i can't believe i
don't even remember being present in
that moment like
when they used to show up to award shows
together like that was an iconic i'm
sorry
love to both of them an iconic moment in
country history yeah and you weren't
present for it because again we weren't
fans of either of them really so they
were just like a long-standing country
couple that you didn't like appreciate
when you had
yeah and you're right about like them
being together makes them so much more
likable because to me like
blake shelton by himself is like
honestly
like not that great of a country singer
and kind of like old news
and gwen stefani is the true definition
of a has-been but
together he is the king of country
she is the king of whatever it is that
she does and like they are going to the
moon
it's just interesting how you know views
change
it is interesting how views change and
do not agree with that no i
i agree i think that before these two
got together
i would have definitely looked at blake
shelton it's just like another
male 1 singer yeah right but now
even looking at him on his own because
this relationship has made me see him
through a different lens now i think
he's everything of the sort but i
i think you were not wrong in your
critique but harsh
have we met no also you know what really
kind of when blake shelton goes to bed
he should get on his knees and thank god
for
every single day the voice yeah yeah
because well it brought these two
together
well that of course but also his career
i feel like
could have been heading in a direction
that was kind of
monotonous or like dead end but he
really got to showcase his very funny
personality on the show i really feel
like that show
gave him on first of all like another 15
years of like
a-list stardom and like
opened him up to entirely new fan base
yeah like that show like
saved him no i'm sure he credits the
show for a lot of things including the
love of his life right like
when would gwen stefani and blake
shelton ever have had a conversation if
not for the voice
mixing genres no it's so true and some
some celebrities go on the voice like to
lend their platform to the voice like
ariana grande is
doing you know the lord's work even like
nick jonas like didn't really need the
voice but then some
but he does feel a need to always prove
himself and show that he is smart
and talented and more than just some
people use that job on the voice to like
literally breathe life into their career
like
remember i mean it was a long time ago
like cello green
like change the game for him even adam
levine a little bit like
he was kind of like right well also i
feel like the voice brought
blake his best friend adam levine who
was absent from the wedding
but in a voice fun fact carson daly
officiated which is just like so oh my
god that's so sweet
so you know he has an appreciation for
the voice okay that's honestly
and he's a down-home southern man i feel
like he knows where his roots are
and his roots are on the voice they
really are yeah
wait that's so cute that carson daly
officiated
yeah because he hosts the voice for
those who don't know which you might not
honestly
yeah because honestly i look you don't
watch a voice it's hard for me to like
watch
other people live out my dreams you know
yeah but you could take your talents to
the voice at any time no
i just want to like wait to to audition
for any of those types of shows like you
literally have to wait online for not
the whole day
not the voice they they kind of source
people based on internet presence like
you can send them videos and stuff
maybe i'll just and they only choose
people who can actually sing you never
hear someone on the voice who's
bad do you want to hear like a really
funny story sure is it
when i was in like my freshman year of
college
every semester at college i took a
two-credit singing class
because it was super easy and then by
the time i graduated i like
took like one class because all these
voice credits every semester
added up to like 16 credits whatever and
they were just like fun and even though
like i had to sing like classical music
it was just like i got to sing for an
hour a day
and my freshman year i was going to try
out for x factor like
100 and i was telling my voice teacher
like this is what i'm training for like
i want to try out for the voice and like
we did classical music but she helped me
i was going to sing lego house by ed
sheeran like i had like this whole thing
planned
and like the the week came that
we were gonna try out and ben was gonna
drive me and like something came up and
like he couldn't go
so of course like okay i lost my ride
like i just didn't try out like
i didn't even try after that like ben
was gonna take man i was gonna make like
you
you know like ben was like bend this out
i was out yeah and i did not have the
heart to tell my voice teacher when i
got back to school
like the after the weekend that i tried
out so like we
we got she was like texting me all
weekend and then we got to class and she
was like how was it it was a one-on-one
class
she was like how was it and like i
actually didn't have their heart to tell
her that like i just couldn't get a ride
so i didn't go
and i was like it was amazing i'll hear
back any minute
yeah and i never heard from her again
her name was jenny she was really nice
that's nice she was like a ta like a
grad grad
student who like teaches like yeah she
was really cool
very nice yeah wasn't meant to be wasn't
meant to be but like i can't help but
think like if ben
whatever came up for ben that day like
hadn't come up
i could be camilla cabello or you could
just be like one of those people who oh
wasn't she on
that one episode of x factor so me it's
like
so hurtful no i just i don't think that
was your path
uh i don't i don't know like when i used
to see fifth harmony like going out and
about i definitely felt like a deep
connection like in some other life like
i could have been a part of that group
a lot of those girls were
interchangeable no offense ally
or they could have been sixth harmony
sure sure sure yeah why do someone like
why there's room for all of us
i think we all deserve to be a fit
harmony okay
are you ready for our next happy couple
news story hcn for sure for sure it's a
lot of hcn today so
sorry if you're not in the mood sorry if
you just got dumped
literally is what i meant pete davidson
matches with
so phoebe devner for wimbledon date okay
you guys
p davidson and phoebe aka daphne
bridgerton
we're at wimbledon this weekend being so
[ __ ] cute
if there was any like non-believers in
this relationship beforehand
i'm sure there were a lot because no
offense like pete davidson is like
a doubtful person yeah in relationships
um
there's no more doubt here because they
literally look so in love and
so cute no like it honestly killed me
because like
these were the most premium pictures and
they were so candid like sometimes you
can tell when celebrities you know
they're being photographed and they'd be
like
cute on purpose no they were just like
accidentally caught in like a cute
moment i'm sure it was like
one of thousands they had that day and
it was actually it was difficult and i
think a lot of people um i feel this way
about this and i think some of our other
happy happy couple news which is olivia
wilde yeah it's
killing me um no i'm like happy for them
it's just honestly i don't know who i'm
more jealous of like
i'm kind of jealous of phoebe of course
she gets like be with pete davidson
who's like so funny and cute and she
also got to like make out with
bridges and pasting the dude so like
she's just like having a really good
year
and also she gets a hookup with nico
tortorella on younger she's just like
having
she gets cast in like good [ __ ] like i'm
jealous of her but i'm also jealous of
pete davidson like first of all he gets
to be with like
the the it girl of the moment like the
diamond of the season literally like
she's so
it right now she's of the moment current
and i kind of just want to be either one
of them i'll take either i don't care
yeah no just i i agree it's hard
it's really hard to see other people
living your dreams yeah and just like to
be so
effortlessly like stunning and happy
happy and like sitting outside so you
can be there's two types of couples
there there are two types of couples at
wimbledon
phoebe bridgerton and bradley cooper and
no
what you wearing and p davidson
and bradley cooper and irina shake
you're either fighting like because you
can't see or it's hot you're complaining
about something
or you're just so blissfully and
naturally happy that like everyone
around you wants wants to kill you
and i think i'm definitely more of an
irena shake and a broadly cooper because
i'm miserable any time i leave my house
especially if it's an outdoor event yeah
um but i'm just knowing that there are
pete davidsons and phoebe burgertons out
there you know it definitely makes me
happy
and it also makes me want to like strive
to be
naturally happy when out in public yes
yes naturally happy and just like
naturally just like so stylish what is
that outfit like
stylish effortless casual comfortable
completely not ever been done before
it's just like it really is something
like
it's something to say these pictures i'm
going to remember for a long time yeah
they give me
major meghan markle harry movie star
blue dress
like some certain photos just strike you
certain photos just strike you i agree
but i wouldn't compare these to those
because those ones were like
they it was paparazzi like they knew and
it was like a magical movie moment that
that was that they were aware of but
this sort of like candid
um in the wild moment
like i'll just be thinking about for a
while no i mean in the way that they
strike me yes i understand it that they
strike but they strike differently they
try differently but like the way that
you know these photos of people i've
never met like can really kind of bother
me like
because it's not me and like give me so
much jealousy like i just didn't know i
could feel that way about a picture
okay which i think is a great segue into
our next story yeah you're about to feel
that way about a picture again because
harry styles and olivia wilde can't keep
their hands off of each other
in italy in photos exclusively obtained
by page six the couple can be seen
enjoying themselves on a yacht
in monte argentario a scenic region
in south tuscany where they've been
vacationing for the past week
the book smart director and the former
one direction crooner were seen dancing
reading kissing and cuddling
i think we can start calling harry
styles something other than a former one
direction band member like he's done
quite a lot he's won grammys but where's
the lie
i mean i guess you could also call me
like the former morning breath co-host
but like that would just be outdated
yeah but there's truth of course um
they spent the afternoon sipping line
and going for a dip in the sea
a dip in the pool but they should not be
swimming in the sea
don't swim in the sea now this is the
thing i saw these pictures and it
definitely took me like a
full hour to kind of process how i was
feeling about them because first of all
this isn't the first time we've seen
harry styles on a yacht it's kind of
like his go-to move with girls he's
dating there are some of the most
sickening pictures
once that stroke me as well um of him
and kendall jenner on a boat like
she was like straddling him it was just
like difficult to see but it was kind of
stunning
um and these i really took time to
process and i realized after seeing them
i do not like them okay i do not like
these photos
at all why don't you like them too much
chelsea well
one jealousy jealousy
i just that should be
me it really should and it's disgusting
that it's not and it's disrespectful
that they would do this
right in front of me and honestly
i'm sorry maybe people won't like this
like i don't ship like at all like i
didn't think these pictures were cute
like just because you hate them so much
or you're just like you actually don't
i just like don't ship like at [ __ ]
all
does anyone see these pictures and think
like great couple no i was like
get away from my boyfriend okay so it's
just no i'm telling you it's definitely
like
70 30 jealousy 70. but just genuine like
distaste for the two of them 30. okay i
can see that i wonder if other people
feel that way like 80 20. i'm not like
so crazy like i like harry styles a lot
i don't want like the stylers coming for
me or anything but i'm not like
we already have the smilers i don't
think that he's like my boyfriend or
anything so i can just like look at this
objectively
okay okay that's great to have an
objective opinion like what do you think
when you see these two together because
i can't tell if it's my blinding rage
but i think they're a terrible couple
like i'm
happy for a happy couple but i think
it's a little overrated
yeah like i just don't see them working
but they do look like
really happy and in love and like
reading kissing and drinking wine like
how much fun is that
i sound like i'm a garden
reading fun and drinking why no but she
always says like how fun is that yes she
does you've been watching too much
discovery plus
will know how fun is that so i'm just
i'm not really world you don't chip even
though they're on one
yeah literally like i don't know i just
i saw these pictures and i'm like
i don't think this is it this is not
your harry story bias because of the age
difference
well you know i like to be honest yes i
am i'm very
think it's weird sorry sorry what's age
difference 10 years
okay that's really not like that but 27
she's 37. it's really not bad that's
honestly like
pretty appropriate but maybe he just
like looks really young
yeah and like she's kids like she looks
more mature to me i don't know i just
i don't like it and i don't really feel
like i have to give you a reason okay no
but i feel like you've
you've you've given us i feel like i can
understand where you're coming from like
when i first heard about it this is your
man like you love him so much and if
he's gonna be like flaunting his
relationship in front of you you want it
to be like
with the right person yeah and like when
i saw those yacht pictures of him and
kendall like
i was so jealous but the pictures were
like so perfect
that i really couldn't even be that
upset like they really are like sorry
like
a perfect match you know very are you
the one but i just don't feel that way
about these photos and when i heard that
they were dating like a couple months
ago i'm like cute like whatever on
screen romance
um now it's just like it's gone on long
enough like let's call it quits
okay but we're still in the middle of
summer so i feel like they're gonna
they're gonna
ride out the rest of the summer at the
least yeah and i just feel like
again like this is what i'm thinking
like with phoebe richardson like
with olivia wilde i don't really feel
like it's fair
but like she got to be married to jason
siddegas like he's such a cutie he's so
funny like
everyone loves him he's like a jason
siegel like you get that for like 10
years and like you just bounce back with
harry styles like honestly
you need to date someone ugly it's not
fair like for the rest of us
and those are my feelings okay and i'm
entitled to them so please don't come
for me you are entitled to them
anything left to say about the happy
couple news in general before we move on
to our next story yeah i'm gonna start
um
like tweeting mean things about harry
and olivia and
make it from my ipvanish so no one can
know where it's coming from
that's great today's sponsor is ipvanish
a virtual private network vpn for short
which is a super important tool that
helps you safely browse
on the internet you can use a vpn on
your computer tablet phone or even
things like a fire stick
when you use a vpn all your data becomes
encrypted encrypted so what you're
reading searching and watching
becomes private whatever it is that
you're doing what you're doing on the
internet is absolutely nobody's business
so ipvanish helps you remain anonymous
and secure on the internet
so for listeners of our show ipvanish is
offering an incredible 65
off for just 3.49 for the first month or
31.49 for the year
here's everything you get with ipvanish
anonymous ip addresses which means your
personal ip can't be tracked so if you
say something mean about
a certain hollywood couple no one knows
where it's coming from you can also
circumvent any online censorship
and get protection when using public
wi-fi so go to ipvanish.com
toast to claim your 65 savings plans
starting at 3 3.49 or 31.49 cents for a
year
now's the time time to sign up with our
discount and the current promotional
offerings you get a 65
off their usual price it's the best of
the best check out ipvanish.com
toast to get our deal and start
protecting yourself online
thank you for that claudia you could
also use it to say nice things about
people anonymous
nice comments yeah that's true sometimes
it's nice should be yeah
um we're done with the happy couple news
right yes
it's just back to regular old news
actually two stories so different from
one another
first and forth um
megan mccain is leaving the view she
says leaving the view was not an easy
decision as she settles into life in dc
megan mccain has officially announced
her exit from the view after nearly four
years she shared the news with viewers
during thursday's episode of the daily
talk show
noting that she will remain until the
end of the month a source told people
earlier that day
that the decision to leave was megan's
she said i'm just going to rip the
band-aid off i'm here to tell you all my
wonderful co-hosts and viewers at home
that this is going to be my last season
here at the view i will be here through
the end of july to finish out the season
with all of you which i am grateful for
this was not an easy decision it took a
lot of thought and counsel and prayer
and talking to my family and my close
friends and you know look covet has
changed the world for all of us
and it changed the way at least for me
the way i'm looking at life the way i'm
living my life and the way i
i want my life to look like she cited
her life in washington dc with her
husband as the reason for her departure
basically doesn't want to come back to
new york but i assume they're still
virtual but the season ends in july i
think they come back from hiatus like at
the end of august or september
and they'll be back in studio hopefully
because like they're like the last show
like andy cohen's back everyone's back
so they're still virtual um seems like
they're going to finish out this season
being virtual
and she doesn't want to move back to new
york which i guess i can understand but
she also had a baby like life is so
different now after covid so
i just found it shocking because for the
most part
the hosts on the view stay like forever
it's like a lifetime it's like a
retirement job like
for the most part when i think of the
view it's a constant
revolving door when i think of the
conservative voices on the view i think
of it more as like there's
i can like there was like elizabeth
hasselback and i forget who i don't i
don't really watch a view but
there's kind of a revolving door but
like joy and whoopi like
barbara walters like the mainstays like
stay on
forever okay that's how i see it but
again that makes sense that does make
sense so
a lot of people are now asking like who
is gonna fill in for her and i think
everyone's pretty much decided it's anna
navarro who
fills in a lot oh that's kind of
anticlimactic i don't
really know who that is because again i
don't watch the video i catch it
sometimes
um sometimes like zach is watching so
i'll um perk up or if they're having an
interesting conversation or i'll see
like a clip on social media so
they definitely have interesting
conversations and i think the fact that
they
showcase a lot of different voices is
really
why it's popular yeah why it's popular
and i feel like a lot of people feel
represented by the show so i feel like a
lot of people are curious who's going to
take this spot to bring on someone who's
like kind of on sometimes
it does feel anticlimactic because i
feel like megan mccain like is leaving
some big shoes to fill because i think
she represents how
a lot of women feel honestly though like
you could not
pay me a billion dollar salary to be on
this show first of all like
i can't deal with conversation like i
would just start crying first of all
every episode i cry
second of all oh my god people are so
[ __ ] mean because it's kind of like a
it gets very heated a lot because it's a
political show and people are arguing
from
different sides of the aisle and it gets
so personal so fast like every time i'm
on twitter someone from the view is
trending and they're like people are
saying to me
people say the meanest thing about like
meghan mccain's hair and they just make
like so much fun of her like appearance
which has nothing to do with her
it's so mean like i would literally if i
was on the view for one day
i would cry and quit like it's the
hardest job so i don't know if i was in
the running but i will not
take the job no i don't know if you were
in the running either but i i can't see
you
as being a good fit i would just cry but
it also was so crazy how they
the women even have these really heated
conversations with each other
and then are like no we're great friends
like they for the most part
i watched the segment because by the way
brian kelly was on the view the day
megan announced her departure which was
just like kind of crazy
um and they all like said nice things to
megan so i watched the whole episode
because i was waiting for brian
and it's very clear that joy does not
like megan like
she i feel like megan and whoopi fight
but they like love each other like
mother daughter
joy like hates megan that's the vibe
that i get and it's not like it's beyond
just the
fighting about politics because for the
most part everyone fights about politics
and they all still love each other and
they work together
i think joy hates megan that's just like
a vibe that i get okay you're probably
right but it's just like i feel like
every time megan was on watch what
happens live which was often
um she talked about it and she says that
they have a really good relationship
maybe that's just her like
taking the high road and not wanting to
like air their feud
but i kind of just took that at face
value like they leave it all at the show
and that they have a good relationship
behind the scenes
now reports are like coming out that the
women wouldn't didn't want to do the
show with her anymore but they always
say [ __ ] like that and even when megan
left she was like
when number she left when she made her
like departure speech she said like
just honestly if anyone is listening
like
she really spoke directly to the media
and how they like talk about and regard
the women of the view
when what they do is like so hard and
like so civilized and it's so
it's honestly like such healthy
political conversations which is so rare
in this day and age
and she said like the way that we get
written about is disgusting and like if
we were five men doing this job which
there isn't a job
isn't a tv show where five men talk
about like the hottest
hot button issues whatever um they would
be spoken about so differently and so
it's true there is like
always these reports and i'm inclined to
believe none of them because
exactly what megan said like the way
that they get spoken about is disgusting
so you don't believe them i i don't
think that i do but i do also think
there's more with the whole joy thing
oh but this one i'm just in page six
this morning and said the view ladies
are at their wits end before megan's
exit
and that whoopi made it clear that she
didn't want to work with her anymore
see i don't think that's true because
from what i've gathered pretty much from
just following megan on instagram was
that her and whippy are really close and
whoopi was really close with her dad and
like
like when megan decided to take the job
like john mccain and we'll be like have
this whole conversation like they're
close family friends so i don't think
that's true
yeah i i i'm inclined not to think that
it's true this story now makes me want
to read that book ladies who punch
i was literally just gonna and i
probably should read it i would probably
love it yeah
and maybe would give me more insight
into whether or not i should believe
these rumors
yeah but again but i also think the idea
of like you moved out of the city during
covet and like
you don't want to move back here and
that's the only way you can continue
doing your job
it's something that probably a lot of
people are struggling with yeah and i
can imagine being like no
you know this is how i see my life i
don't want to go back to that hellhole i
wonder what she'll do next though
yeah i don't know we'll see i feel like
there's a lot
that she could do and we'll keep you
abreast on who gets that seat but i
feel like it's gonna be on navarro like
she's a guest
host all the time and those jobs are
usually like meant for training people
who eventually are gonna take a seat you
think so not to bring in like a bigger
name
i don't know i don't know i'll have to
i'll check it out
check it out okay our fifth and final
story is not so much a story as a
listicle that i found interesting and
funny
i [ __ ] hate listicles okay but this
list
because like buzzfeed and they're like
okay 24 cheeses you need to eat of your
virgo like what
but this one is cnbc it's a business
listicle can you go with that
a bistical a mystical shirt these are
the 24 overused words and phrases that
make you sound
pretentious according to grammar experts
that your managers and your direct
reports do not want to hear you say oh
you mean in a business sense yes
obviously the first and i definitely
know two of them okay sorry
sorry to bother no or just
no but that's like a different um that's
a different lipstick
like wow i wouldn't get any of them okay
no but these are sorry you won't feel
it's two separate things okay i'm just
gonna go through all them they're all
pretty much like phrases that like
two words or three words that all mean
the same thing and you're just using
extra words
okay first is three a.m in the morning
three a.m this morning what the [ __ ]
says that
apparently people also absolutely get a
job if you say that
also absolutely essential means the same
thing
again who the [ __ ] is speaking like this
next
actual fact i feel like we could say
that sometimes
okay i okay i could see myself saying
that yeah next
at this point in time what's wrong with
that
most uh why not just say now
at this point yeah i guess i i feel like
that's like a little dramatic
yeah it's fine to say that i'm taking
that one off the list next depreciate in
value
well i guess i could appreciate it alone
inherently mean to lesson in value
yeah next eliminate completely
eliminate means completely removed no
sometimes you need like an extra
like if you really feel strongly that
the mckenzie file needs to be eliminated
immediately
or whatever no but that's different than
eliminated completely no like
no i think like sometimes when like
someone a subordinate is not
understanding that the mckenzie file
needs to be
what is it eliminated completely
eliminated completely like you have to
you know rule with an iron fist
sometimes i think an extra oomph goes a
long way okay so we're gonna take that
one out yeah
combined together okay that's stupid who
says that
i guess i could see myself saying like
we should combine these two parties
together or
join together that's like a phrase i
would think but come together
right now about at this time
end result what's wrong with that i
don't know the result is at the end of
something
not always an unexpected result on your
journeys are like really harsh
you know when like whoever wrote this
like i don't want to work for you like
you're
so nitpicky next estimated at about
i never even heard of those words like
all three of them i'm not familiar
okay exact same [ __ ] off okay it's the
exact same
it's fine it's fine it's fine
favorable approval
like i can't even imagine one
circumstance where i would ever say that
she received favorable approval it's
just a mouthful but why is it wrong
because um approval is always favorable
oh i guess it would be like favorable
feedback
yeah okay that actually that low-key
tracks yeah
next one feel badly for some people
uh for some reason many people think
adding the lead to bad makes it sound
better so they say i feel badly instead
of i feel bad but that's wrong
well you do sound like a two-year-old
like i feel bad but then if you say i
feel badly you're like a sophisticated
business woman
yeah it's like that winnie the pooh um
meme where he's like smoking a cigar
yeah like you're happy so honestly
i think that one can say okay general
consensus of opinion
no general consensus period great in
close proximity
my oh because proximity means close yes
so
just say close honestly like i'm getting
angry and angry with this article like
leave people alone this next one is so
hurtful everything of the sort
in my opinion
when you're sharing a perspective or
insight readers will already get the
concept it's your opinion
this is like no sometimes you need to
need to be
like so that you're not like correcting
someone and being rude just be like in
my opinion either yeah not like they
should be this way right because so much
of like being in the corporate space is
not about speaking perfectly it's about
not stepping on other people's toes
so you have to say things like you know
the general consensus like you have to
you have to
and it's about not hurting people's
feelings that's on corporate culture so
if you want
people to not talk like this it starts
at the top not at the bottom in the
emails
next one in the final analysis
yeah that's dumb finally or in my
analysis
in the process of totally perfectly fine
leave us alone yeah most unique
why unique means unlike anything else so
you can't have gradations of uniqueness
it's unique plain and simple oh that's
so silly and so dumb yeah past history
or past memories past records
which you know is a double negative it's
just like a double whatever but
it's a double tense sometimes you gotta
hit that word count in the email
you can't just be sending like a
two-sentence email yeah no i'm very very
very very grateful and appreciative
of your time and effort yeah postpone
until later
i guess i'm looking over this article oh
but you don't think some of our business
savvy toasters would want to know
there's nothing useful in here who wrote
this cnbc
why don't you work on some new episodes
of american grade and stop wasting your
time on these dumbest listicles leave it
to buzzfeed okay
it's gonna be like which business jargon
is your cancer sign like
shut up shut up seriously what business
jargon do you think is your cancer sign
though
uh oh ooh because i'm constantly out of
office
yep what about you um oh i love business
jargon so much i know
circle back i love to circle back um
you also love to follow up by eod yeah
but i also like when i text and stuff
like i talk in business jargon
i don't even realize my friends say that
i text so formally like especially if
i'm like
writing to them just in a capacity of
seriousness like
if you know i'm asking a favor or
something hey guys i don't want to
bother
just curious it's so ingrained the
businesswoman special is
so ingrained in your dna you don't even
realize when you're doing it this is
courses through my veins
courses you think we'd be more
successful
okay those are the bad side stories i
feel as though you needed to know them
you did and we can finally now talk
about what we've been dying to talk
about which is
our review of netflix's season two of
too hot to handle brought to you by
coors pure
do you ever feel like living a balanced
life is hard like you try super hard to
keep up with what's with what is
considered
balanced well welcome coors pure it's
organic but chill about it
the new coarse pure is a refreshingly
simple beer with organic barley organic
hops and water
at 92 calories and zero sugar it is the
perfect beer to celebrate the winds of
everyday life
of course pure is all about promoting
balance and giving aggressive
affirmations to everyday heroes
whether you just got that run in or you
just got as far as putting on your
running clothes
course pure is celebrating you don't
forget it's organic
um coarse pure is a perfect beer to
celebrate the winds of everyday life so
summer is around the corner you find
yourself on a beautiful summer day
wanting to drink a course pure alfresco
you could do it guilt-free
with coarse pure organic so when you
want to enjoy a beer without the guilt
reach for the course pure it's organic
but chill about it
go to coorspure.com toast to find where
uh you can find a quarth pure near you
that's c-o-o-r-s-p-u-r-e
dot com slash toast celebrate
responsibly coors brewing company
albany georgia love it thank you for
that i needed a coors pure after
watching
too hot to handle i needed several
because oh my god the first four
episodes that they dropped
while it wasn't revolutionary i thought
it was cute and i thought that they did
a good show of
a good job of like casting interesting
people while also shifting lana's rules
then in the second half of the episodes
we got four and then i think we got
five it became impossible to watch
because first of all throwing new people
into the mix did not do anything either
the people had no respect for the rules
and got sent home or they were just
uninteresting like that girl l was
stunning and then like i literally
forgot that she was even there because
she wasn't talking to anyone yeah so
that didn't fix anything and then
this group just had no respect for the
prize so there was like nothing at stake
there was nothing to lose there was
nothing at stake and so
i mean i think giving it to one person
made it kind of interesting
towards the end barely it's just such
a a it's such a nothing premise for a
show on
and the money again like it needs to be
a million dollars
and there was no incentive to keep
watching like there was
no growth there was no like no one was
evolving like cam and emily were the
strongest couple and like they were just
boring for a while and then he was like
i'm having doubts and it was just like
fake no and it's like cam was nominated
to win because he said no to getting in
the shower with another girl that was
the growth
yeah it's so stupid honestly the one who
really did show the most growth is
marvin yeah and marvin and melinda
actually like were the saving grace of
the show and
even they didn't really help like i was
so bored that final episode where the
whole episode they're voting
and like you have to watch flashbacks
and then for i skip skip
skip i was like skipping and i'm like i
can't believe we still haven't found out
who this one person voted for
they tried so hard to add a ninth
episode if they made it seven or eight
episodes it would have been better but
oh my god that last episode
so painful it was a powerpoint
presentation like it was so boring
it was so boring then melinda and marvin
which were really kind of the saving
grace of the show i thought they both
i'm obsessed
with melinda i'm like she's coming up
with tick tocks now she's
gorgeous nominated for the grand prize
because
of what she she changed marvin and what
she brought to the show which she
brought to the show and also but like
she she also changed herself because the
way she started out with marvin to the
to the place that they got in their
relationship like she
exhibited so much growth like i really
just saw the carly storyline like i'm
sorry i had
no time for it so now wait some offline
drama okay
so melinda and marvin otp we loved him
they left boyfriend a girlfriend
literally this morning or maybe last
night melinda posted sexy pictures
with peter that little short guy
who got sent home from staten island oh
my god so like in a romantic way in a
sexy way
and like the comments were sexy like
between them it's like a sexy thing
okay so now we don't know where that
stands kim and emily posted a picture
together yesterday like they do seem to
be still be together they both have a
million followers they have the most
followers from the show
emily's like so gorgeous i'm obsessed
with her and like i had no respect for
her for like hanging out with cam he
like not he's not even that cute and
he was like sure like i just didn't
understand why she wouldn't be with
someone else like that guy jack was so
slept on he was cute
who's that the new one at the end who
came for carly joey
joey yeah what did i call him jack cool
same thing um and yes
the carly storyline like was super
boring even though like i really did
like carly a lot she was just giving me
absolutely nothing to work with and
what's so funny is that
you texted me i texted claudia because i
actually was ahead of you in episodes i
was watching all day thursday
and i texted claudia saying hold on i
just want to pull it up
verbatim yeah i think it's really
important yeah that we get it word for
word i think were you a little ahead of
me at this point
yes i was ahead of you and i said to her
chase is the biggest loser
on this show she she wrote back
no he's nice so i obviously hadn't made
it far enough and i wrote back
no fast forward to last night at 7 51
p.m claudia texted me and you know
claudia has no memory
none claudia texted me chase is the
biggest loser on this show
and i screenshotted our conversation
from four days before
and sent to her and she was like oh my
god she had no clothes so sometimes you
guys all takes his four days because
this is the thing this is the thing okay
he's a loser for
many reasons one he was wearing
turtlenecks the entire time and it was
so [ __ ] hot like i don't know why he
was wearing turtlenecks
with silver chains he looked like that
picture of the rock first of all second
of all he's a loser because like harley
wanted to have a helpful conversation
with him and he just dumped her like
that's not growth
first of all then he's such a loser
because he like fell
in love with this girl tabitha who's
just like a party girl and was like not
even interested
and i'm sorry that scene on the beach
where he like kind of you know like
opened up her and she was like honey
it's just a holiday romance
was literally the best moment of my life
and that's when i texted you chase is
the biggest loser on the show
because he thought he was such hot [ __ ]
like running around the property with
marvin like
oh [ __ ] and then like literally became
the biggest loser on the show like
you absolutely love to see it like
someone getting their ass handed to them
which they so rightfully deserved so i
texted you chase is the biggest loser on
the show a few episodes
prior not that anything in specific like
specifically happened but his
interviews like were just giving me such
losery vibes and just everything that he
was saying was just sounding so losery
and
i felt like in the beginning in the
first episode he was one of the guys
that
most girls were into and then the fact
that he ends up with no one just like
shows how big of a loser he is and that
his personality just sort of
push them all away and so if you think
he's a loser now like wait until you see
his tick tocks okay
he is being like so clickbaity like he
has over a million tick tock followers
he's been tick-tocking since the
episodes came out like making up rumors
he like literally has a tick tock that
kind of implies like emily and him are
like talking and
she's coming to see him but then like i
went to go check emily's instagram like
she's happy with cam so
he's like being thirsty he's doing all
these tick tocks like oh i won't you
know make a fake relationship for clout
and tagging marvin which kind of implies
like
melinda and peter's really like he's
just being so thirsty and he's like
lip-syncing to all these songs
and he doesn't know the words which is
my biggest pet peeve like don't lip sing
a song if you don't know the words so
he's literally like okay sing a song
and i'm gonna be i'm gonna be chase lip
syncing it okay okay
honey time we gonna have a good time a
thousand hands up to the sky
we gonna get toasty tonight like he's
just moving his mouth and it's
infuriating to watch
um but he's having a lot of success on
tick tock like people are flocking
because they're like curious what's
going on now
um and according to chase's tick tocks
like he's literally
meeting up with emily like it makes
no [ __ ] sense this is the first time
i watched a reality show where i like
when i finished it
i just turned it off and like opened my
kindle as opposed to stalking every
single cast member and trying to find
out
what's going on right now because that's
how he like went to l.a to hang out with
harry jowzy
and obviously like harry jowzy like went
to catch and like call the paparazzi on
himself
and you know chase is there like you
know pretending the paparazzi's for him
and like he's taking the videos from tmz
and like putting it on
his tick tock and it's just honestly i
blame harry jowzy for giving
these men false hopes yeah that they
like
what harry jowzy actually did has built
so impressive it's
really impressive francesca too
francesca too like went from like a
one-season wonder and like really has a
business
and podcast like influencer lifestyle
like
he's got a good thing going it's not
just like 15 minutes and i really think
i really think cam like looks in the
mirror and sees harry chelsea
no no and emily emily looks in the
mirror and sees francesca's
yeah and it's just it's not the same
it's not because
when did two out to handle come out were
we in copenhagen we were in covenant and
we were clearly desperate for content
and we had just come off of watching
love is blind and we thought this was
gonna be as good and it wasn't but it
was still good
yeah it was still good but we also got
really interesting cast members and when
i finished the episode
um the season finale it started playing
season one
and they do like a recap in the
beginning of what we can expect for the
first season one and like i do think
season one was a much better season with
like
much more interesting people this was
like actually atrocious and it was so
bad
so dreadful so boring i will never watch
the show again like i'm
i'm so done with it like the event like
the time
that they took out of my life like i'll
never get that back and i'll never get
the brain cells back and that's the most
beautiful part i won't get i have so few
left and i'm just like giving them out
like free candy i need to really be
you need to protect conservatives with
my brain cells 100
yeah i agree and i'm glad that you see
my side and you see that i wasn't just
being a hater grandma
no no i'm i'm such a [ __ ] hater no
and i i apologize like i was wrong like
you were just like this show sucks and
i'm like girl like it's not a historical
fiction that's why you don't like it but
you were 100 right i couldn't see what
you saw
the writing on the wall i'm so sorry you
were 100
right this was such a piece of [ __ ] show
like i actually
i actually except for melinda i like see
these people on instagram and i have
like
like a tick like i have a visceral
reaction i hate them because they
bothered me so much on the show like
i hate them and that's how i'm feeling
with chase right now like his tick tocks
are
actually like i have to go to anger
management like that's how angry they're
making me
except for melinda can you block someone
so they don't come up yeah but like it's
like
it's like a thing like i hate but i love
to watch yeah and also melinda
i hope her tick tocks never go away
she's literally just like making the
world her runway
strutting like naomi campbelling down on
like some random [ __ ] street
it's so premium she's actually i think
maybe the prettiest girl to ever come
out of a reality show yeah i can't get
over it and her
hair and makeup was so stellar the
entire time
i just i actually stan no i 100
and she's the only redeeming thing about
this season
truly but they tried us
the house was really nice though yeah
what do you think it was
it was in turks and caicos oh i was
gonna say it was giving me tricks and
cake goes by they said it was turks and
caicos
i really wasn't paying attention yeah
trash
absolute trash save yourself the time go
watch season two of are you the one on
netflix it's literally so [ __ ] good
now you need to watch some other seasons
of are you the one because there's oh i
started so many
season one last night with ben because
ben finished it with me and he's
obsessed
it's just a really good concept and when
i was watching too hot to handle like
and i since i've always watched already
the one i'm like this would be so much
better if like if you just had are you
the one vibes or if these people were on
are you the one like we just need a
better premise
yeah and honestly i think that netflix
is casting
the same people like all these people
are like professional
instagram models like and the thing
about are you the one that i liked was
like these were just
actual regular people who like weren't
perfect looking and like
made questionable fashion choices and it
made the show so funny and interesting
and it's like a little too perfect like
everyone's dresses is amazing everyone's
body's so
snatched and perfect with their little
titties like too much like
give me some chaos give me some claire
crawley energy it's true
are you the one is very much like just a
a perfect show
singles imperfect yeah
but perfect for one another no you mean
oh yeah are you the one yeah
yeah so just watching those two even
though they're like not similar like
it really highlighted how bad two how to
handle is i will not be watching ever
again like i'm [ __ ] done they've
disgraced my time and my energy my brain
cells
i'm so happy to hear that because that
means i don't have to watch ever again
and that is our show any other content
we watched this week on now we were
together i started this book called the
lions den oh we also watched vampire
academy which
i loved so much but claudia couldn't
appreciate because people were being
loud the whole time it was such a bad
movie like you know i
no it's literally so good i wouldn't say
best movie ever because like you know
confessions of a shopaholic is out there
but
yeah because movies like confessions of
a shopaholic exist yeah but vampire
academy
is really good it's star-studded it's
based on a series of books and then i
was like i should read the books because
you never got a sequel to the movie
because there was haters like you out
there who were like don't give it to us
um and i would like to know don't give a
talk i would like to know what happens
to
vastly but i would like totally be a roy
right
ah you can see me dedicating my life to
someone else
a drogon or whatever they're called here
yeah yeah yeah it would be
yeah 100 yeah that's very true
i would be a sure guy you would be mri
see you didn't like it no i didn't um
and so i wanted to read the books but
then i had just watched the movie and it
was wait
it was so redundant i was like this is
wasting my time so i started lions den
which is
so good um you'll like it i think
everyone will like it i really do but
i'm only sixty percent of the way so who
knows what happens but it's like
more than half yeah but like what if the
end is you know so unrewarding
you still like the book you never know
um
okay cool well that's all i had to say
cool cool
and that's all she wrote is it yeah she
looks about done
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast the millennium morning
show where we deliver the past life
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so
if you're watching this on youtube to
subscribe give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast and
we're podcasting me down so it's spotify
itunes stitcher public radio ihot radio
cast box
all the places so wherever you listen to
a podcast find us more and enjoy sleep
if i starve you about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are
hope you guys have an amazing day we
will see you tomorrow already for
home day goodbye goodbye
[Music]
goodbye